Yeah.
His voice was very unique too in that he decided to combine fiction with
nonfiction in a very weird blurry way.
I think it was.
So one thing I think of is he usually gives you a cue where what he did was he
dramatized,
people didn't dramatize.
Wait a minute,
man,
shit up.
He didn't just dramatize.
There's a rumor.
It's doctor,
I didn't say that there.
He did April gate.
I said there was,
this is about Ed Muskie's campaign.
Um,
I said there was a rumor in Milwaukee that he did it again.
I started that rumor.
Yeah.
I mean that's what he says,
but what did he said that on the Dick Cavett show later?
And I think Matt Taibbi on this show talked about it.
Well,
where one thing is that,
um,
muskie was already out of the campaign.
When that came out,
it must be had already lost.
And so muskie had been a fucking monster and a terrible person on that campaign.
And so Thompson used that version of Musky and wrote,
as Toby said,
in a very straight way,
it began story.
And so if you had a sense of irony,
you kind of knew like you're not really thinking that this is a guy who did able
gain,
so I think there's queues in there for our listening audience,
but what I think is even more,
you know what?
I think he dramatize the way other people didn't.
He would say,
I look left,
I look up,
I see.
He came down to me and then he said people didn't write like that in journalism.
They didn't go step by step.
And he did.
And that was really important.
What I think is more important than the IV.
Again,
story.
So the biggest story in the background is Ed Muskie was the front runner for the
Democratic primary in 1972 he fucked up his campaign afterwards.
Thompson talked about how he had heard that there are,
there was a rumor that this candidate was doing Ibogaine,
which is like Iowasca or he said that,
no,
it's not like Iowasca.
It's not.
No,
it's very different.
So hallucinatory,
it's a self examined Tori.
I was the one who get off.
Get off.
Yeah.
But he said they brought in a Brazilian,
which doctor I've again is not even a Brazilian drug from Africa.
People got it.
But what I think people don't remember is before that,
and this affected the election.
And um,
February of 1972 Thompson was in Florida.
He was on something called the sunshine special.
It was a whistle stop tour that Musky,
the front runner had a good chance to beat Nixon,
pull numbers wise,
um,
was um,
going all the way down the Florida peninsula on to try to win the Florida
primary.
And Thompson was like,
this is the most disgusting thing I've ever seen.
Like at every stop Musky gave the same shit speech.
It's like somebody should be your president,
namely me.
And it was repeated.
The reporters were like,
fucking,
this is terrible.
Muskie was secluded in the back of the car.
He didn't interact with anybody.
They had his political operatives come out and make everybody like sing the song
like,
um,
about like Musky,
like sunshine in his hands,
the whole world in his hands.
It was terrible.
And so that night Thompson pulled into a Florida town.
It was the second to last stop.
And he in this young political reporter named Monte Chitty,
we're going to get a drink at 2:00 AM.
And this guy walks into the lobby,
he's like six,
six,
two 50 Peter Sheridan.
And he,
um,
he walks in and he,
he says he's looking for the muskie campaign,
all these different things.
He ends up going out with them,
a hundred Thompson for a drink and a hunter.
Thompson finds out that Peter Sheridan had been a good friend of Jerry Garcia,
had um,
hung out with the hell's angels in,
um,
California.
Had,
um,
been to La Honda where Ken Kesey was and was actually a pretty smart guy who was
out of his mind in his mid twenties.
They stayed out and drink all night at the end of the night.
Thompson was like,
so what are you doing tomorrow?
Where you going?
And,
um,
Peter,
Sharon was like,
well,
I'm going to Miami.
And Thompson's like,
we are too.
You don't have to hitchhike.
Fuck that.
And so there's a really good journalist outlaw,
um,
it's called outlaw,
journalists by bill McKean,
the tea.
Another Thompson biography.
He talks about how Thompson took his Thompson and took his press pass,
put it into the um,
elevator press,
the button,
sent the press pass down to the ground floor.
Peter shared and got it.
So Peter shared and could write for free on the Sunshine Express Down to Miami
the next day.
So Thompson over sleeps because the fucking muskie campaign doesn't like him.
Anyways,
instead Peter shared and gets on the sunshine express with a Hunter Thompson
Press Badge and Peter Sheridan goes on to order 12 martinis and he goes,
give me like a triple gin bucks.
Hold the book.
And he runs up and down the car and you know,
Musky has been a really shitty candidate at this point.
He's not been engaging people.
He got in this weird fight with his wife at a,
um,
a campaign event where they like put cake in each other's face.
It's been really weird and people aren't reporting on it.
Like other reporters aren't saying muskies on stable.
And so Musky at the end of this whistle stop,
he spent all his campaign money to go up and down and try to do this whistle
stop tour.
He gives a speech at the caboose and Jerry Rubin,
the antiwar activist who was one of the Chicago seven,
um,
and was,
it has come to heckle him,
is in the crowd and he's saying the mosquito.
So why did you support the Vietnam War in 1968?
Like,
who do you think you are?
And so muskies yelling at Jerry Ruben,
he's,
Hey,
young man,
keep your mouth shut.
But neath Musky reaching up from the bottom of the caboose.
Peter Sheridan is holding a gin bottle and grabbing it muskies leg as a Musky
tries to give this speech.
And then Musky falls back in.
The whole thing ends.
Like the whole press conference is over,
like women's wear daily reported this and it came out that Hunter Thompson had
had 13 Martinis and run up and down the train and had interfered with it.
And muskie's campaign really believed that Thompson was working with Donald
Segretti and Nixon's.
I'm creep,
um,
Watergate crew to fuck up Muskie's campaign.
And that actually changed the course.
It like Thompson help expose how fucked up muskie was as a candidate at that
time.
And Thompson had never forgiven Musky for being on the pro Vietnam War Platform
at the 1968 convention.
And so we talk about the implicate aspect of changing the campaign,
but that report and the way that disseminated through media,
the way it was picked up by other newspapers really did help change the people's
perception of Ed Muskie at big Ed Muskie as a topic called him at the time.
Now he,
when he wrote Hell's angels,
he hadn't really totally formulated that sort of Gonzo style of journalism,
but he did have a little bit of fiction mixed in with that and that sort of ran
him a foul of the hell hell's angels.
They were very upset by that.
Right?
Like he,
he did write some things in there that they claim or not accurate.
I think that when it came to hell's angels,
um,
what Thompson did really well,
that's what Joan Didion did really well.
He took the way the media was portraying somebody and he stripped that off and
said,
this is who they actually are.
This is what they're actually doing.
Joan Didion,
when she writes about Jim Morrison and the white album,
she's like,
Jim Morrison was like,
sex and death in his leather pants was the best thing ever.
Everybody loves Jim Morrison.
And then in the scene and the white album,
Joan Didion writes about how they sit at a recording studio for two hours and
nobody says anything and they eat eggs out of a paper bag and it's a fucking
nightmare.
Thompson knew that the media was sensationalizing the hell's angels.
He went to them,
um,
on a cold night in San Francisco.
I'm down by the waterfront and he said,
hey,
here's a Newsweek article.
Here's a time article.
Here's how everybody's running about you.
All I want to do is write the truth about who you are.
And he did and he ended up writing with them.
Um,
and he ended up spending time with them.
I don't think they got as mad at him about the way he portrayed them.
I think they got mad that he began to make money or that he became famous hell's
angels.
So 500,000 paperback copies,
that is almost impossible to imagine today.
500,000 paperback copies of a Literary Book and the angels were pissed off about
that.
They felt Thompson owed him more money,
owed him something for that.
Did he hit him at all?
Did he give them any money?
Barker,
Cindy Berger's.
So ridiculous,
silly buggers said he owed us a keg and he didn't give us a cake.
That's it.
You know the famous story at the end of it is that that is,
I mean really like when they go through it,
he said that he said the Thompson was doing this objective version of us,
but it was at least closer than the shitty news.
We can time versions.
And so Thompson at the end of,
he'd finished the book,
barely made the deadline.
I had to go down to a hotel in Monterey,
lock himself in step for a hundred hours straight and write it in March of
[inaudible] 67 to finish it.
So it turns it in,
makes it as,
um,
advanced deadline in September.
They're like,
here's our author photo and it's Shitty.
And he's like,
fuck this.
So he goes to a hell's angels rally.
He doesn't know anybody because he hasn't been with them for six or seven
months.
He's taking pictures.
That's when he got freed up from writing about the hell's angels and he tiny his
friend who later committed suicide after Ultima after being involved in the
Altima security situation.
Tying the rolling stone one where the youngest staff,
yes.
Where Meredith hunter was stabbed,
but tiny.
It was a woman that got stabbed.
The man marathoner.
Oh.
Um,
it was a man named Meredith.
Oh was back in the day where you can name your kid's Meredith,
right?
Like Marion,
Marion's another one.
Right.
Um,
Lindsey,
some guys are Lindsey.
I can honestly give me one Jamie.
Oh yeah.
But Jamie's normal.
Well,
if there's a lot of Jamie's the future man scene where it's like,
what's his name is like,
my name's Susan in the future,
men are named Susan.
I know it's a girl's name and your time.
Um,
but here it is a weird one though.
You must hate your fucking saw on the map but lose the argument with your wife.
But that
lost a lot of arguments with my,
but that poor guy was um,
but Thompson was there and tiny grabbed him after he was beat up.
There's a guy holding a rock to drop it on.
Thompson with the hell's angels.
And tiny was like,
all right,
I know him,
I know the rest of you don't.
And he grabbed him out and tiny was um,
this like enormous hell's angel who had been,
you know,
Thompson was pretty good at empathetically understanding their flaws and their
perspectives.
He never,
I think made excuses for him.
He said that their inherent perspective as fascistic,
he writes that,
you know,
he says they use violence to respond to where they were in society.
Their idea of total retaliation.
The hell's angels were any offense,
like looking at you funny or being like,
dude,
you drink.
It could be met with everybody beating you up because they got determine the,
they got the hell's angels,
got to determine the offense.
Like that was fascism to Thompson.
And he wrote beautifully about their reliance on violence cause he,
they felt hell's angels.
They'd been left behind by our moderated society.
Like there's technology,
there's all these new jobs.
If you came back from the war in 1950 you had a chance in Oakland to have a
middle class life in a beautiful house,
in work the rest of your days and have a family that will then go on.
But by 1965,
that was no longer an option.
And the angels were a violent response to that.
Very similar to what we're seeing now.
So the way he wrote about the hell's angels.
So very similar to the way that we see violence within groups that are
supporting Trump,
you know,
lifted in the right.
Did he ever wind up,
um,
resolving his differences with the hell's angels?
I think so.
Sandy Berger,
hell's angels got fucked.
Like rightly.
So.
The hell's angels were,
you know,
pursued like a mob.
Um,
like,
um,
like a mafia group.
People went to jail,
sunny barker went to jail.
Um,
I think they at the end appreciated his representation of them because it was
better than any other ones.
There's no better representation of the health.
They know more sympathetic for sure are just no more accurate,
no more understood.
Winked.
Yeah,
no more like,
again,
I guess the Thompsons effort,
if you ride for six months with somebody and you're an honest,
like putting up your hands,
you're not trying to fit what you see into a thesis,
you're doing the opposite.
Trying to look at the reality you have in front of you and then form an argument
out of that coherent,
that's what Thompson's gift was and very dangerous to,
to do that.
I mean,
I mean he did get beat up taking those photographs,
really bad motorcycle accident with his friend on the back and his friend broke
his leg like it was,
that's why he left.
He's like,
get the fuck out of San Francisco.
Yeah.
Face looks amazing.
Like it's amazing.
It's a,
it's a fire that you're putting your hand on to.
How did it crash?
He was coming down.
Um,
it was with the mayor of Richmond.
He was coming down as slick road and they had,
um,
hit a UN,
like something was wet or an oil thing and it went out the back tire.
So Thompson rolled and was fine,
but his friends knee hit,
um,
railroad tracks.
So it's friends need broke really badly.
Um,
it the mayor,
yeah,
it was the mayor of Richmond.
And that's continued riding motorcycles though.
I,
yeah,
he did.
He would get in accidents at Woody Creek,
but he was pretty careful,
like,
so I love that scene in Hell's angels.
I don't know if readers,
our listeners know this,
but the edge,
you know,
and that's a major part of the book where Thompson's fighting with his wife.
Thompson's finished his book,
but he's breaking down because he's worked so hard to do it.
And so he takes his BSA out and he goes,
if he knows San Francisco,
he goes out to the park,
he hits the Coast highway,
and he comes down it and he's like,
I'm so overwhelmed.
Everything is so fucking terrible.
He's going as fast as he can.
And he talks about how his eyes began to lose moisture.
You,
you know,
the scene like this,
this beautiful scene,
he's looking for sand pits because he hit a sand pit near the zoo.
You're fucking dot.
Yeah.
And he gets all the way to Rockaway beach,
which is in,
um,
like halfway down to Santa Cruz.
And he turns around and what he talks about is when he's at a hundred miles per
hour,
and I think he was near death,
he was really overwhelmed.
He says,
um,
you know,
the edge,
the only people that know it are the people that have gone over the rest,
the living,
don't have any understanding of that.
And all we can do is approach it in this way.
And it's this beautiful and is called midnight on the coast highway.
It was a anthologized and Tom Wolfe,
you know,
and it was just beautiful.
So he comes back and he sits at his desk and so he had a view of the bay bridge.
He could see it's two flashing lights,
um,
the whole time.
And he had broken the window and a terrible fight with his wife like three weeks
earlier.
Um,
and so he sits at the broken window and he writes out that scene right away with
his eyes,
still scoured,
avoid using the broken window when she wouldn't give him a gun,
cause he was on acid and he threw a shoe through the window.
There's three,
there's three versions.
So I do it and then I give the three versions of the notes.
So I go with the three versions that I've heard,
like I heard it from,
I'll ask her,
you know,
she wrote,
I really respect sandy like deeply.
She wrote at the,
um,
uh,
a few years ago,
she said,
I'm done giving interviews about honest Thompson.
That was my life.
That was then,
she's given so many interviews up to this point.
She says that that exist.
And so I wanted to respect that more than anything and just use the information
that they had on,
you know,
and let the reader know,
Yo,
here at three other versions,
here's the best version I could make.
Dramatize,
look left,
throw,
do this.